people normally when they talk about me
they go from attack double up to Star
Wars has a few years in between year
where there has been a lot of knows a
lot of you're not right enough
I stayed in LA with no money I stayed on
my friend's couch and I lost my
accommodation elsewhere so do you want
to be the biggest movie star in the
world or do you want to I don't know
what that is but I'm gonna do me and
however you guys want to define it you
can't define it for whatever is what's
that belief nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you and I
want to see that great thing that you
have inside of you come out so you can
help change the world so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna learn
from actor John boyega and my take on
his top ten rules of success rule number
one is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well enjoy
so what's been your lowest moment I
think it's um a lot of it has been the
reality that your circumstance does not
in any form match to what you want to be
yeah my reality just did not represent
me being in a Star Wars movie or even
being an actor because it was just basic
yeah I know we never know any basic it's
not a bad thing it's it's it's a cool
opportunity that we all get we get free
education we get you know at least
decent home even if he's government
housing whatever you have a roof but you
know it was my circumstance did not
reflect and did not give me any clues as
to what my future would be so to have to
make that decision and sure like I mean
you understand you change your life and
make a decision that is is uncanny it's
it's a it was a it was a big low point
but after getting into it and just doing
it right it turned out to be so yeah
value cuz was bomb about that is I was
just talking to a friend of mine and we
were discussing how life is 10%
circumstance and then 90 percent your
attitude you have that circumstance yeah
and it takes it takes a lot of time too
it takes some people short amounts of
time and some people a longer time to
kind of get to grips that you know what
no one's gonna scout me life isn't just
gonna pay me a million dollars I'm gonna
have to probably work my ass off just to
survive and you know honor my Nigerian
family yeah I think that you have are
you confident that you have enough
self-confidence and belief in yourself
that you'd get to where you want it to
be were you ever worried what's gonna
work out yeah of course I mean I just
tell myself shot corner of choice but I
mean I had great experiences even in
terms of the opportunities that I didn't
get with Matthew Vaughn I was able to
work closely with him during an audition
process and then you know with the Maze
Runner and all of that despite the fact
I didn't get the roles so there's a
great opportunity
are you particularly ambitious or you
just wanted to be interested in your
work you know I'm ambitious by Nature
which is it is what it is you know
failure is a part of the process but I
just I like success I like get things
done
um and it's something that has been
opposed
have impacted my life I'm going to the
goal and achieving is there's nothing
like it so should you keep on putting
the bar further out for yourself err
oh yeah definitely that I mean I mean
this why would I why would I be doing
back to back interviews going on planes
all the time and you know it's a harsh
life but nights it's a commitment it's a
commitment you know doing this is a
commitment I just feel like sometimes
you don't want to do it and what pulls
you through is ambition I wanted to
achieve something that's nothing wrong
with that should you want to be the
biggest movie star in the world or do
you want to I don't know what that is
but I'm gonna do me and however you guys
want to define it you couldn't define it
for whatever is but I want to do me for
sure and I'm just wanna be the best that
I can be and I want inspire other people
to do what they want to do at air lives
in well regardless ways just be the best
you can be I just had a question because
we have a lot of aspiring actors and
even struggling actors who listen to the
show and everybody wants that one moment
where they're like yes I'm in a big
movie or I got a big opportunity yeah
when JJ called you and said you're gonna
be the star of the new Star Wars movie
what was the first thing that came to
your head brakes were you like hell yeah
groupies like a PPD oh man I mean I was
relieved I was relieved if you've if
you've worked for so long I mean people
normally when they talk about me they go
from a tech bubble up to Star Wars has a
few years in-between year where there
has been a lot of knows a lot of you're
not right enough and and it's a lot to
take in so to be rewarded for the
failures and the hard work and the
persistence when JJ told me face to face
I was just like okay now I can really go
home like I can really you know go to my
parents and you like exhale okay cool
yeah one of the things that I think a
lot of people respect about you is with
your platform you still speak out about
issues that matter one of those being a
lack of diversity in Hollywood you
talked about Game of Thrones and sort of
call them out for a lack of diversity
well gives you that confidence to speak
on those issues still being you know new
and young in your career but being bold
and just saying exactly how it is
I don't know
don't know I just don't decide things
that don't like and when I don't like
here I just you know I have to speak out
about anything all these good
contrapositive conversation to have I
think the more people at their
perspective the more you kind of teach
everyone to have a conversation about
something and I think with those
statements people are starting to talk
about about the important things what
made you want to be an actor in the
first place I just like it
was it something you did as a kid or was
it yeah that I thought as a kid and I
and I enjoyed it I enjoyed the
performance I felt good doing it for him
lucky now in a really good space and
it's the side of yourself once you
discover it that you just continue to
explore and then it moves into a job and
a serious thing - what happened to me
I've always loved it when did it change
for you and to work into a career when
when I started going to my drama school
so well I knew I wanted to take you
seriously because that required a
significant commitment of time and then
I started auditioning getting headshots
started making money to invest it back
into trips to LA and became a serious
thing I did a a pilot for HBO called the
grip with Spike Lee that didn't go to
two season that's gonna be a little that
was a llama yes so so after that I kind
of left America alone I've done a few
things back in the UK and I came back
out of the states many times I was back
and forth just auditioning meetings
trying to make make something happen
did I hear correctly you were like on
the shortlist of four Kingsman that's
that one oh yeah yeah Kingsman almost
happened The Maze Runner almost happened
and they didn't you know that wasn't a
huge bummers at the time does it get
easier or does it each one of those
thing Maze Runner was particularly hard
because I I stayed in LA with no money I
stayed on my friend's couch and I lost
my accommodation elsewhere on the hope
that obviously we were down to like the
last two and right you know the time the
team was very keen that you know it
would go through and it didn't so I was
kind of like oh I'll go back to London
now for me I always liked a director
with good balance and what I mean by
good balance is enough vision number one
and then enough freedom for the actors
to be able to do their jobs so I the
style of acting that I choose to take
for each role I love to be the character
I love to becoming not in a method type
of way but in a scene I like to watch a
movie I'm in back and feel like I can't
remember doing that stuff by watching
Star Wars half of the things Finn does
in that film I can't remember making a
decision to do it because it was a there
was instinct and there was freedom and
there was the ability to be able to be
creative and JJ is a big advocate of
that I mean he would we would start a
scene with the dialogue and he'll be
like all right let's just do your
version and let's just do a version that
you guys feel free with and that's how
Harrison works as well and improv really
makes way for magical moments and when
you have a director that has a good
enough balance to understand the
technical point of view for at least a
good shot
color correction visual effects
practical effects but then he has
artistic knowledge also for character
arcs dialogue and and fun it's always
good so that's what I look for what
inspired you from Delhi more work oh
yeah we'll work it's bigger there's more
roles there's more opportunity there's
bigger things to be a part of the
narrative in the UK was getting boring
to me I just felt a little bit like
there wasn't any stories that I just
wanted to be a part of that without were
just different and dynamic and and
granted itself a great career move so
most of us go to come to the States it's
kind of like now the norm you know to
come here for better opportunity my last
screen test for the role JJ came up to
me and JJ was just like we we really
want you you know to book this part but
in order for us to do that we need you
to have a really good eye line and he
brought out Chewie and I'm just like you
know what just roll the cameras because
this is so emotional for me right now it
was chewy in real life just walked and
you know it's just there in the hall and
I'm just like oh oh it's right there and
- and to perform with him on set
is a whole other experience because you
it's a symbol it's like you I'm in a
Star Wars movie I'm replying to to
Chewbacca right now I'm like holding him
and stuff you know I had him all the
time I mean there were moments you get
back in the car you like Huey Harrison's
Oh first of all I have to say this
however since my best friend honestly he
is he won't exactly say it like that but
he is and it's pretty cool having an
actor like Harrison who is who has been
there and done that to see him relive
the excitement of coming back it's just
ridiculous like Harrison was as
passionate and was as enthusiastic as
this as if this was his first movie and
so for me it was it was really enjoyable
working with someone who was still
buzzing to just go on set and shoot III
you know you sounds like you're joking
best friends but I read that he when you
were in London a few days ago yeah this
was probably something you wanted to
keep private but got out in the news
anyhow you took him to like you're where
you grew up the neighborhood you grew up
in your favorite restaurant as a kid
yeah
can you talk a little bit about that
experience sir yeah I mean we we were it
was while we were filming we were on the
Falcon and as you do and I was like by
the chess set just messing around and he
was just like boyega I really want to go
to our spot that so
really want to go to a spot that's
enjoyable and sick of chicken burns in
the veggies also you know a place
I just thought yeah man you can come
come to where I grew up so I was just
like you know you're gonna have to like
ditch to secure either because that
would just be too much you just go with
me we'll eat some food and you just like
okay cool when we went to just like 10
minutes from where we shot attack the
block actually we just went to the area
and we and we sat down we just had a
Nigerian food like and he was ordering
everything and you know for people who
are African Caribbean you know you know
you get a bit of a that's like a sleep
medicine after that Harrison was slumped
in the car back he was just like the
food just got him and he does well the
spices too but people were starstruck
but I think about Nigerians are be you
know Nigerians are kings regardless what
the bank account is saying so after a
certain amount of time they can you know
he we were able to just have a normal
meal which was fun
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Luke Johnson
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson are you going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leaving
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Mike from Illinois Mike
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one-word posted a
picture onto Instagram I hope you enjoy
the read and I appreciate your support
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
did you ever like you don't have the
usually when people come up here they
tell a story of strife and struggle and
you know I was in the streets and I shot
a few dues they shot me yeah yeah yeah I
live to tell the story now a rap career
yeah what you don't have that I don't
have that never been shot I've never
shot anything okay you know I stayed
away from all of them yeah I decided to
take my life seriously all right man
yeah yeah I'm 23 I'm trying to be rich I
can't do that when I'm dead I first
heard about Star Wars after Disney
bought Lucasfilm for like you know four
pounds or something and then they
announced that JJ was on board for a new
Star Wars movie see as an actor you tend
to think okay where's the opportunity
gonna come from and family finally Femi
my agent called me and just told me that
we have an audition for you it's for the
new Star Wars movie and the breakdown
was boy one charming funny hero girl one
strong independent hero and I'm like
come on guys are you thinking more than
this but then I went in to audition and
through the process JJ gave me notes
that then carved from the the rock of
confusion the Finn that we know today
[Music]
or ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon table ignition if you want
to know what the most important one word
is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]